e
peter kornblue director of the national
security archives chile documentation
project led a campaign to declassify
documents regarding the u.s government's
relationship with the pinochet
dictatorship in chile next on book tv he
details his findings it's an hour and 15
minutes
last thursday
was the 30th anniversary of the 1973
coup
in chile
and we're very honored to have mr peter
cornblue here his new book is called the
pinochet file
peter cornblue is director of the
national security archive a library of
declassified us government material
based in george washington university
and he's written several books
based on documents that have been
released by the us government
on iran contra the bay of pigs the cuban
missile crisis this is a very important
book it's a very interesting book
um
it
leads one to the impression that
well
it's a very controversial book as well
but one of the things that has always
been argued by those conservatives in
chile was that
the coup was in it
something that happened from the inside
but what this book clearly shows is that
there was an awful lot of stuff going on
from the outside and ladies and
gentlemen i'd like to welcome mr peter
cornblue
[Applause]
thank you so much it's uh
so nice to be here it's so nice to see
so many familiar faces people i worked
with for many many years
um
you know and i know and i think you know
that a large community has been built
around the issue of chile
many people including some who are here
today came directly from chile after the
coup and started
organizations here in washington to work
towards human rights and the restoration
of democracy
there that in some ways changed the
history of of of our country certainly
changed our laws and i think had a great
impact on on people like like myself
um
and it was always a great satisfaction
for me knowing that uh in writing this
book i might make a small contribution
uh to that to the work of that community
and and and and take my place
in it
i want to start with a declassified
document but but of course a
declassified document this is a book of
built around declassified documents let
me just tell you what it is
this is a memorandum that henry
kissinger's deputy at the national
security council a man named byron vakey
wrote to him on september 14th
1970. september 14th was 11 days
after
socialist leader salvador allende was
elected
democratically to the presidency of
chile
he hadn't been inaugurated yet and
wasn't due to be inaugurated for another
six weeks but he had been elected 11
days earlier and already
the white house was considering what
kind of covert actions
might be implemented to keep him from
actually assuming the presidency and
this is what kissinger's deputy
wrote to him opposing
u.s covert operations
to thwart allende from becoming
president
what we propose vicky wrote is patently
a violation of our own principles
and policy tenants
this is a secret sensitive memo by the
way
moralism aside this has practical
operational consequences
if these principles have any meaning we
normally depart from them only to meet
the gravest
threat to us
example given to our survival
is allende a mortal threat to the united
states fakey posed this question to
kissinger and he answered it
it is hard
to argue this
these words i think resonate today as we
discuss whether in today's world we face
mortal threats abroad
and what the appropriate u.s response
should be
chile also resonates
as an example an original example a
rather classic example of a pre-emptive
strike
think about it the day after this memo
was written
kissinger
ignoring this advice went to a 15-minute
meeting in the oval office with richard
nixon on september 15th cia director
richard helms was there and we have
richard helms's handwritten notes
from this meeting the orders of the
president of the united states
this is a rather famous document i don't
know how many of you have seen this
document before
very very few of you only only a small
handful
um this document has actually been
around for almost 27 years
it was declassified during the special
senate investigation into chile in 1975.
this is an important document this is
the only extant document the only
declassified document we have
of the president of the united states of
america ordering the overthrow of a
democratically elected government
certainly we have declassified documents
going way back of presidents ordering
the overthrow of
of
other regimes not elected ones ones that
came to power through armed force such
as fidel castro's etc but this is the
only one we have
of a president ordering the rollback of
a of a decision by another country to
democratically elect their leader
and this document reads one in 10 10
chance perhaps would save chile
worth spending 10 million dollars
available more if necessary no
involvement of the embassy don't tell
the ambassador
this is a full-time job best men we have
give me a game plan and then the most
famous line make the economy scream i'm
going to pass this document around just
because i want people to be able to see
it for themselves
this was richard nixon saying to the cia
i want you to foment chaos in chile make
the economy scream do what is necessary
to create a situation where by the
military uh moves to block allende from
actually being inaugurated president of
chile now think about it
preemptive strike this document is dated
september 15 1970. allende is not due to
be inaugurated for another six weeks
until november third
1970. he has not yet assumed the
presidency
he has yet to implement as president of
chile a single
a single policy detrimental to u.s
interests
and yet
nixon had decided
as cia director helms told his staff the
next day that allende was and i quote
unacceptable
to the united states
and had ordered the cia to foment
this coup
the country of chile
the chilean poet pablo neruda once
described his country as a long petal of
sea wine
and snow
how many of you have ever been there
well a good a good many of you and you
know
you know that this is
a beautiful
beautiful country
it starts with an extremely dry desert
in the north and it ends with glaciers
in the south
and in between there are lots and lots
of vineyards and
grapes that turn into wonderful chilean
wine and copper mines and
the songs of victor hara and inti limani
floating in the air it's a it's a
beautiful beautiful country
and naruto obviously captured what a
what an extraordinary place it was
now kissinger henry kissinger once
described chile
as quote a dagger pointed at the heart
of antarctica
what did he mean
he meant that of course
chile was a country dangerous to nothing
it was a weapon pointed at nowhere um it
had no strategic importance to the
united states
but i'm here to tell you tonight that
that was before allende's election on
september 4th
1970. he uttered those words in 1969
in a conversation with chile's foreign
minister
who was trying to get him to pay more
attention to the southern cone
and his response was well your country
is a dagger pointed to at the heart of
antarctica
really not so much worth my time
when it became apparent
to dr kissinger in the fall in the
summer of 1970
given the polling in chile that ayane
might actually win in a three-way race
he ordered the intelligence community
state department's bureau of
intelligence and research the cia's
western hemisphere desk the defense
intelligence agency to all do an
assessment
what would be the impact of allende's
election on the united states this was a
threat assessment the type of thing that
all the agencies were doing about iraq
over the last uh two years or so
um
and the intelligence community did a
full-fledged national security study
memorandum and they came back with the
following conclusion one
allende's election would not change the
balance of military power the balance of
power in the world
uh
chile under allende would pose no
strategic threat to u.s interests
the only impact of allende's election
would be a psychological impact
on other countries in latin america
which might want to follow chile's lead
and move peacefully through the
democratic process to elect
uh reformers and
and uh political figures who would
institute through the democratic process
substantive change that would affect u.s
economic interests obviously and u.s
diplomatic interests
that was the assessment of the
intelligence community
that is not what however henry kissinger
told
richard nixon
first
under nixon's orders of september 15th
the united states tried to foment a coup
covertly
a very small group of cia officials
trying to find a chilean
military clique that would move against
allende
that effort that operation led to the
assassination of the chilean
commander-in-chief general renee
schneider
on october 22 1970 schneider was the
equivalent of the head of our joint
chiefs of staff
he was a constitutionalist he opposed a
coup none of the military under him
would move without his orders and so the
cia and the three or four chilean
generals they were working with came up
with this 17-point plan which i've
actually
uh copied and put in the book
that would start with general
schneider's
kidnapping he would be kidnapped he'd be
secretly flown to argentina
a coup plotter would replace him as
commander-in-chief
they the military would declare that
allende's supporters had been
responsible for this kidnapping they
would declare martial law sweep through
all of the shanty towns where
alien supporters lived arrest people
kind of decapitate the opposition
uh annul the elections and then
and then the plan kind of stopped there
there was no call for return in
democracy there was no scheduling of new
elections etcetera that plan is is in
the book at the bottom of that plan by
the way is the request to the cia for
fifty thousand dollars
to pay
the group that was going to undertake
this this kidnapping
instead of kidnapping schneider
he was shot
and killed
the cia
headquarters in langley sent to cable
which i've also reproduced in the book
the next day
uh basically commending the station in
santiago
for an excellent job that's a quote an
excellent job in bringing chileans to
the point where a military solution
is possible
for them
of course anybody who observed chile
anybody who knew anything about chile's
strong tradition of democracy and the
lack of any political violence in the
recent memory in that country would
understand
that a shooting of this kind
would rally the chilean people around
there around their leaders this was an
act of terrorism in chile that was
tantamount to
to to an act of terrorism here in
washington to really was the equivalent
for chileans at that point of of the
kennedy assassination here for us it was
it was a shock a shock to the system and
of course the chilean congress two days
later ratified allende overwhelmingly
and he became president on november
third
kissinger 48 hours later november 5th
brings us rather comprehensive set of
briefing papers
these are them
to richard nixon
and he says to nixon
tomorrow you're going to hold a national
security council meeting
and it is absolutely imperative that you
lay down the law
to everybody
in the national security bureaucracy in
the state department the defense
department the cia that you want allende
opposed as strongly as possible
if you don't do this kissinger argued
they will be a drift towards a modus v
vendi
with the allende government because the
state department is believes that
there's nothing we can do
except live with allende and hope that
he becomes unpopular and is voted out in
1976 i oppose that kissinger wrote
he wrote to richard nixon this is this
is rather extraordinary he wrote to
richard nixon
allende will seek to quote
be internationally respectable
move cautiously and pragmatically
avoid immediate confrontation with us
move slowly in formalizing relations
with cuba
and other socialist countries
these are all the things that he said
that he said allende would do
it doesn't seem so outrageous does it
but for kissinger this was allende's
game plan this was a way for him to
somehow lull the united states into
thinking
that they could get along with him
and for kissinger he laid out a series
of issues
that was a threat to the united states
in fact he
said to nixon
the main problem with allende is that he
is going to set an example
the example of a successfully elected
marxist government in chile would have
an impact on and even precedent value
for other parts of the world
especially italy especially countries in
western europe
and the initiative spread of a similar
of similar phenomena elsewhere would in
turn have a significant effect on the
world balance and our own position in it
and this is kissinger now goading
richard nixon it's it's amazing to
listen to the way they they discussed
these these issues together
the election of allende kissinger says
to
to richard nixon poses one of the most
serious challenges ever faced in this
hemisphere and your decision
as to what to do may be the most
historic and difficult
foreign policy
decision you will have to make
this year and he goes on to argue all
the reasons why
the richard nixon must lay down the law
and that is what that is what nixon did
i'm going to pass around
the meeting the next day
of nixon and his national security
council uh
aides the vice president the secretary
of state secretary of defense
i just want you to be able to see what
i've been able to see which is the way
that
that our highest u.s officials discussed
together in a conference room the future
of another country regime change right
that's really what it was this was an
explicit discussion about regime change
in chile you have the secretary of
defense melvin laird saying we have to
hurt allende and bring him down and you
have the secretary of state saying yes i
agree with that we have to hurt him
and bring him down but we have to do it
in a way that the rest of the world
doesn't see what we're doing
because obviously allende's legitimate
leader of chile he's democratically
elected we've repeatedly stated that we
respect the international sovereignty of
other countries and democratic will
of other citizenries
so we can't openly
do this we have to have a hostile
approach but but disguise it as a
finesse it as a
as essentially a cool and distant
approach rather than rather than of us
aggression let me just send this around
to you it's one of the most
extraordinary documents that that that
was declassified in the last several
years
let me talk about the documents
as i just inferred the value of these
documents is extraordinary you and i can
be a fly on the wall
as the highest u.s officials discussed
um and deliberated um
strategies for for
uh u.s foreign policy in this case for
for bringing down
another government for determining the
future of another
country
we can be in the room
when decisions are discussed when
objections are raised
when orders are given
and it really these documents really let
you understand
the mindset
of our highest leaders and the president
appears in many of these documents
kissinger appears in many of these
documents
his aides present him with counter
arguments and many of these documents
you unders start to understand the way
foreign policy makers think
about other countries the way they have
a sense of their own power
and the implementation of that power
in other countries
and you certainly get a sense a very
detailed sense
of the actions
taken
i just want to describe to you um
very briefly
how
we got these documents and and how
i was able to use a whole new gen a
whole new set of declassified records um
to try and reapproach
uh the history of u.s relations with
chile
as many of you may remember
um
it was going to be it's going to be five
years
uh this in just a few weeks in october
october 18th i believe
that
augusto pinochet was arrested in london
this was a stunning event
it shocked the world
it delighted many many people
who had been waiting a long long time
for this to happen and never believed it
would frankly there was a small group
particularly of spanish lawyers one of
them a former spanish aide to salvador
allende
who had spent
25 years after the coup
trying to work on human rights in chile
trying to adjust and rewrite the laws in
spain uh to make spanish law uh
applicable to pinochet's crimes and it
eventually succeeded in doing this so
spain as you may recall had petitioned
london for pinochet's extradition he was
vacationing in london he had hurt his
back decided to have back surgery it was
laid up in a private clinic
the london clinic when spain
through interpol served an arrest
warrant on him
this created a huge
outcry
around the world um
an effort around the world to to present
the evidence of pinochet's crimes
in the united states
where pinochet's secret police had
committed an egregious act of
international terrorism
uh the september 1976 bombing car
bombing of orlando latelier's car and
killing him
pinochet's leading critic in the united
states former chilean ambassador here
and his american colleague ronnie
carpent on september 21st 1976 right
down there in sheridan circle i'm sure
many of you have seen the small monument
that is there but pinochet in other
words had committed a crime here and
there was a pressure here on the clinton
administration if spain was going to ask
for pinochet's extradition why didn't
the united states ask
for pinochet's extradition on the
grounds of prosecuting this act of
international terrorism and the the
families of of pinochet's american
victims
the families of ronnie carpenter moffatt
the families
of orlando lately those that were living
here and as well as isabel his widow who
was living in chile at the time
um
pressed very hard for for for that case
to be reopened joyce horman the widow of
charles hormann the american killed
after the coup also lent her voice very
loudly
to pressuring the clinton administration
to help with the prosecution
of of pinochet in spain for a variety of
reasons
the clinton administration did not want
to add to the concept of universal
jurisdiction
there's a fear in this country that
american officials will someday come
under the globalization of justice uh
and that the pinochet president the
pinochet precedent is not particularly
good for
officials like henry kissinger
uh perhaps others and so the united
states is not
uh very fond of supporting that concept
uh and so the administration decided not
to directly help the spanish with
evidence
but we in my office and and many others
worked with the administration from the
outside through through political
pressure from congress through through
through newspaper articles media
coverage and from the inside to the
context that we had with with very very
strong courageous officials inside the
clinton administration to say look if
you don't do something here
if you don't make some kind of gesture
in this case you're simply going to be
protecting one of the vilest
dictators
in the recent history of
of south
america of latin america
why don't you just declassify all the
holdings on the pinochet era why don't
you just declassify the cia reports on
pinochet's atrocities the cia and
defense intelligence agency reports on
pinochet's terrorism inside chile
outside chile etc
and eventually the administration
decided to do a major declassification
project not just on the 17 years of the
pinochet dictatorship but actually even
back to
u.s holdings on
on the allende period this was an idea
of some
some conservative in the in the state
department who said well if we
declassify documents on pinochet we have
to classify documents on allende because
he was a socialist and he did bad things
and we don't want to seem imbalanced
against pinochet we need to declassify
documents on on allende also
well i i could only stand back and
applaud this
this decision because in so doing
this particular individual opened the
door
to forcing the cia to declassify
documents on its involvement in
political violence and terrorism in
chile in other words all the covert
operations that took place
between 1970 and 1973 to undermine the
allende government
twenty four thousand documents
were declassified over a two year period
twenty four thousand secret documents
that we hadn't seen before
and they told an extraordinary story of
u.s policy starting in 1970 before
allende's election and ending in 1990 uh
with pinochet
being voted out of office in a
plebiscite and actually turning over
power
to to civilians at least partially
turning over
power to a civilian government
and the documents you know there were
quite a few of them 24 000 and if you
even if you put them in order and if you
divide them up day by day you almost had
coverage
of almost every day of that 20-year
period and certainly the most critical
days of that 20-year period and it
allowed us to go back
and revisit this history
it allowed me to take a stab at
rewriting
this history
both the history of u.s efforts to
undermine salvador allende undermine
democracy in chile and the history of
u.s efforts to bolster augusto pinochet
particularly in the first three years
after his coup
we've just passed the 30th anniversary
of the coup in chile
a lot of focus was on
that three-year period 70 to 73 and what
the united states did
i'll leave it to you to to examine the
first two chapters of the book and the
uh 25 or 30 documents that go with the
first two chapters of the book
to have a sense of of what new we've
been able to learn
i wanted to spend just a minute with you
though talking about the post-coup
period which we're in
right now
what was going on 30 years ago today
on september 16th
and i can tell you from the declassified
documents what was going on
secret back channel efforts to
send messages to augusto pinochet that
the united states government would
avidly support him
a whole series of meetings in washington
cable traffic down to santiago
secret intermediaries going to
augusto pinochet
starting on the 13th of september 48
hours after the coup and going all the
way through
in the weeks uh to come let me just
share with you um the first
cable
that went down to uh santiago
to the to the embassy giving them
instructions on what to tell
what to tell
augusto
pinochet
we had henry kissinger uh who was up on
capitol hill at this very same time
fortuitously uh coincidentally he was
being confirmed as secretary of state
the day after the coup and his
confirmation hearings were being held
and of course he was peppered with
questions
about the u.s role in the coup and what
u.s policy was towards the new military
junta and he said to them
we are neutral
towards this change of government
so we didn't want to make the mistake
that we made in 1964 when we ran out and
embraced the military regime that took
power in brazil
at that time we learned our lesson then
we're remaining neutral now
at the very time he was saying that to
the senators
top secret cables were being sent to
the u.s embassy in in in santiago chile
uh to pass a message to augusto pinochet
and this cable is titled u.s government
attitude toward junta
the us government wishes to make clear
its desire to cooperate with the
military junta and to assist in any
appropriate way
we agree that it is best initially
to avoid too much public identification
between us
and so we are pleased to maintain
unofficial contacts
um
only three or four days later
a similar cable went down
we want the government of chile to know
of our strongest desire to cooperate
closely and establish firm basis for
cordial and most constructive
relationship
the documents allow you to
see behind the scenes what was going on
and these cables are being sent at
almost the identical these cables are
going down to chile at the identical
time that ci intelligence reports are
coming up from chile
on massive uh bloodshed
massive bloodletting by the chilean
military
the cia
even though engaged in specific covert
operations one wing of the station
they're routinely reported on various
aspects of repression as did the defense
intelligence agency
uh in santiago so you have literally
dozens and dozens of reports on
repression starting from the day
following the coup and going all the way
up through to the late
1980s
the bloodshed was so widespread
in the days following the coup
that
um
that the ci sources really couldn't even
accurately count how many people had
been killed by the military uh one week
after the coup of cable came up saying
that 4 000 civilians had been killed in
the aftermath of the coup
another cable came up a few days later
saying that a source that said from
anywhere from two thousand to ten
thousand civilian casualties uh uh had
had
taken place
because of the coup and after the coup
um
a few weeks later the ci intercepted a
secret report that had been written by
chilean military for
the junta to report on the exact figures
how many people were killed in the three
weeks after the coup how many people had
been arrested how many people have been
detained where they were being detained
etc and in the three weeks following the
coup
um
according to this intelligence report
about 12 to 1 300 civilians had been
killed
350 to 400 of them summarily executed 13
700 have been rounded up taken to the
national stadium
in chile
and there
several hundred were actually
executed among them two american
citizens charles hormann
and frank taruji
we can chart our policy makers response
to to this information we know when
kissinger received reports of these
atrocities one of the most extraordinary
documents was a declassified transcript
of a kissinger staff state department
staff meeting on october 1st when his
assistant secretary for for latin
america comes in right from capitol hill
capitol hill and he says you know the
senators have have been saying to me you
know what about these massacres what
about all these deaths um and and the
assistant secretary says kissinger can
it be true what what should i tell what
should i tell the senators and kissinger
says point blank to his staff i want us
to understand our policy however bad the
behavior
of this new military government it is
better for us and for our interests than
allende was
that was the policy that was that was
laid down
to um
to
you to us officials
kissinger
really had
a disdain for the issue of human rights
he believed that human rights got in the
way of diplomacy and power politics he
was
a man who believed in real politique
at one point when the u.s ambassador
sent up a cable that talked about human
rights atrocities in chile he scrawled
on it cut out the political science
lectures
um
the declassified transcripts of his
meetings are rather extraordinary they
reveal attitudes that that are even you
know even hard for for someone as jaded
as myself
uh who has studied dr kissinger's
policies in chile to to to to to believe
as the repression got worse and chilly
over the first couple of years
kissinger
came under increased pressure from
beneath from his own staff
to bring up the issue to to to press the
issue of human rights with the chilean
regime
he really didn't want to do this and he
seemed to be more critical of the people
people in his own state department
raising the issue than of the chileans
themselves and i'll just i'll just give
you an example this is a
a memorandum of conversation
between kissinger and and pinochet's
foreign minister in september of 1975
foreign minister patricio carvajal
and the foreign minister comes into this
meeting and
in all these meetings there would be a
note taker would take shorthand and then
the shorthand would be transcribed and
you'd actually have a full transcript of
everything that was said which
fortunately exists today
and those of you who worked on human
rights in the mid 1970s in chile will
will appreciate this the foreign
minister comes into this meeting
and and the first thing he says to
kissinger is i want to thank you for
giving us this opportunity to talk to
you
and kissinger says to him well
i read the briefing paper for this
meeting and it was nothing but human
rights
the state department is made up of
people who have a vocation for the
ministry
because there are not enough churches
for them they went into the department
of state
and that that was the attitude that
that he professed we we have
uh we have another transcript uh which
is
which is equally extraordinary
and that is a transcript
of henry kissinger's private discussions
with augusto pinochet in chile in june
of 1976.
pinochet's staff had pressed him
to say something about human rights to
go to the oas
conference in chile and make a speech
about human rights
and they touted this to the u.s congress
into the american public as a change of
u.s policy the united states was going
to pressure the chilean government on
human rights and in his memoirs the
third volume of his memoirs kissinger
writes about this meeting with pinochet
he says you know i went in there and i
talked to general pinochet about
democracy and human rights and i told
him he had to clean up his act or or
usaid was going to get cut off i pressed
him on this issue pinochet complained
kissinger writes that that his friends
the united states was treating him badly
and i returned to my theme of democracy
and human rights that is what kissinger
wrote uh in his
in his uh
memoir
we got the declassified transcript of
this actual meeting
which is amazing uh that it survived um
and that we now have it to compare
to what dr kissinger writes in his
memoirs
and what he does in this meeting is he
goes in and talks to pinochet and
basically says look this is what i'm
going to say and this is why i have to
say it
and i want you to understand this
and this is actually what he says he
reviews with pinochet what he is going
to say in the speech he's about to give
the speech two weeks later
and he says
i will call attention
to
to human rights
i can do no less without producing a
reaction in the united states which
might lead to legislative restrictions
on aid
military and economic aid with you
the speech is not aimed at chile
he says to pinochet
i wanted to tell you about this
my evaluation is
that you are a victim of all left-wing
groups around the world and that your
greatest sin was that you overthrew a
government which was going communist
just a few minutes later in the meeting
he is talking to pinochet and pinochet
is complaining as kissinger wrote in his
memoirs that the united states is
treating him badly the united states
treats its friends barely and kissinger
writes in his memoirs as i just said
that i return to my theme of
human rights and democracy in fact when
you read the transcript you see that he
did not return to this theme
pinochet complains
you have a punitive system for your
friends and kissinger responds there is
merit in what you say it is a curious
time in the united states
it is unfortunate we have been through
vietnam and watergate
we have to wait until the elections the
election the 1976 uh election between
ford and carter we welcomed the
overthrow of the communist inclined
government here we are not out to weaken
your position
and at the very end of the meeting
uh
kissinger says we want to help not
undermine you you did a great service to
the west in overthrowing allende
this is the type of history that the
documents
[Music]
gives us
it enables us to return to the issues of
the past to re-examine them
to understand how they're relevant to
today many of the issues that were
debated around chile
issue of u.s intervention the issue of
regime change the issue of preemptive
strike the issue of
honesty and dishonesty in government
these two issue of covert operations and
controls over them
the issues of
what was being done in the name of the
american people around the world
in their name but without their
knowledge all those issues came to play
in chile when you study chile there's
there's an echo
obviously in in in the present that's
worth considering but
on its own
uh it is worth evaluating as a case
study of morality and immorality
in the exercise of u.s foreign policy it
continues to to plague
u.s foreign policy makers
right on the eve of the war in iraq
a questioner stood up and asked
secretary of state colin powell how the
united states could argue on moral
grounds that we should go in and
overthrow saddam hussein given what we
had done in chile overthrowing ayenne
and supporting pinochet
and paul's response was in chile in the
1970s it is not a part of our country's
history that we are proud of
i'll stop there i will take any
questions that you have
and
thank you again for for coming
[Applause]
can we have people line up here and ask
you questions through the microphone
here would that be okay can you announce
that there that's fine i don't know if
that mic is working too loud um i'm i'm
willing anybody can line up there and
people want to shout out their questions
so everybody can hear you can do that
too
you need people to be at the microphone
or if you repeat the question
they would like people to go to the
microphone and ask the questions in this
first case i will i will um repeat the
question which was do i do i think that
kissinger is indictable for orlando
lately or ronnie moffatt
you know
i think the answer to that is no
there's a fascinating story of what the
u.s government kissinger's office and
the cia knew
about chilean plans to assassinate
critics abroad
prior to the lately or moffett
assassination
and it's a story that is told in the
book all the documents telling what
prior knowledge the u.s government had
about this consortium of secret police
agencies in the southern cone called
called operation condor
that was the the mechanism under which
uh
assassins terrorists came to washington
and planted this bomb
um is rather amazing for more than 25
years
we
only had one declassified document on
operation condor and the lately
assassination and it was an fbi report
dated a week after the assassination and
it appeared to be in
it appeared to be an intelligence report
uh it was an fbi intelligence report
based on intelligence gained from
argentina
uh and
it said that it is likely that the
assassination in washington
was a phase three operation of operation
condor
and for 25 years we thought given this
document that u.s government officials
had learned a week after the fact about
operation condor and then when all the
documents were declassified several
years ago we found out that in fact the
cia had known five months before
the lately or moffett assassination
about condor and its assassination plans
excuse me not the specific
lately or mission but the fact that
these governments and the secret
services secret police agencies of these
governments had met together and had
designed a plan to to coordinate uh
surveillance on their critics around the
world and to send special teams out
to
kill
specific critics
in europe in latin america
and in the united states
in the book i have the intelli the
report that was given to kissinger on
august 3rd
1976 about
this intelligence and what to do about
it
and it turns out that this was a case in
some ways it resonates so so forcefully
with our own september 11 2001 this is a
case where there was abundance an
abundance of intelligence um that could
have been put together in one place uh
and some response issued that would have
detected and deterred this mission and
for a variety of reasons that was not
that was not done the most ironic
extraordinary document is a document
dated september 20th
1976
in the late afternoon from the assistant
secretary for latin america saying let's
close down all efforts to say to the
condor countries that we oppose what
they're doing because there doesn't seem
to be any active assassination
plans afoot
18 hours later the bomb went off
at sheridan circle in washington
we have a line of people i'll keep my
answers shorter
uh what role did ambassador nathaniel
davis who was in santiago at the time
play in all of this
nathaniel davis was our ambassador
starting in 1972
in chile he left
in the fall of 73 after the coup
he was there in the final months of
allende and was there in the initial
weeks of the the pinochet regime
he um played an interesting role
he opposed certain plans that the cia
had to to directly
sponsor
protests and agitation and strikes in
the street
he sided with
another state department official back
here in washington
in suggesting that the cia not be so
aggressive because for him it wasn't
clear that the chilean military was
actually ready to to foment a coup and
he was concerned that the united states
would
be directly implemented in a failed coup
or
etc and he just didn't feel that that
was given that you see i had already
participated in a failed coup three
years earlier in the fall of 1970 um he
he actually opposed that he however was
very aggressive in trying to promote the
junta from the moment that it that it
took office um he sent back a series of
cables some of which are reproduced in
the book suggesting aid to the junta he
personally came up with the idea of sen
of the cia
uh secretly sponsoring a tour around the
world of members of the chilean
christian democratic party uh to present
a justification for the coup uh to
europe and and the rest of of of latin
america and diplomatically and
politically and economically uh he
pressed very quickly for aid to be given
to to pinochet there is a a document in
in the book um
uh where he of a conversation he has
with pinochet
as he's getting ready to to leave
santiago
and return to washington which is which
is
quite interesting actually
uh what has been the consequence of the
doctrine of universal jurisdiction
issued by the spanish judge first of all
what happened to pinochet was he ever
tried and you know adjudicated and has
it ever been a precedent has it ever
happened again
it is a a precedent
and i think it has had a very
significant impact
specifically to pinochet pinochet spent
a year under house arrest in london more
than a year
um
back about the the the british courts
ruled repeatedly that legally he should
be extradited to spain to stand trial
a behind-the-scenes deal was cut
between
the british government and the chilean
government which didn't want pinochet
sent to to spain
they preferred that nothing happened to
him but since this had been a very
embarrassing episode they argued
that they would prosecute him in chile
and that would be the best thing for
chilean nationalism and for the chilean
legal system if he was prosecuted there
so he was sent back to chile at that
point i think all observers of his case
thought that this was over but in fact a
very aggressive and courageous judge
judge guzman
in santiago pressed forward with charges
against pinochet
he was actually indicted there he was
stripped of his political immunity
and at one point he came about this
close to having his mug shot taken and
being fingerprinted
eventually after a whole round of of
court votes all the way up to the
supreme court the court ruled
that
for the same given reason that he had
been allowed to leave london
that he could not be tried in chile and
that was
mental incapacity mental dementia
at that point that ruling he was about
85 or 86 years old
he immediately
after this ruling wrote a letter which
was quite coherent for somebody who was
mentally demented
announcing that he was going to withdraw
from public life and that he hoped
chileans would understand the great
effort he had made on their behalf
during during his
time in in government
um but the impact of of that case
certainly has led other countries to
press uh for similar types of of cases
uh around the the world i think it has
empowered the international court of
justice where milosevic is being uh
tried right now there's a case that's
going to be taking place right here in
in in the united states in florida
starting on monday with the chilean
family uh whose brother was killed uh in
what was called the caravan of death
which i described in the book which was
a kind of a death squad that pinochet
sent out after the coup uh to fly into
other provinces of the country and take
people who were had been put in prison
allende's civic leaders the sheriffs the
mayors the police chiefs
etc they had all been imprisoned after
the coup but he sent in a helicopter
squad and everywhere the helicopter
landed
at night these political prisoners would
be taken out of the prison and and
marched to a ravine and shot and a
number of them had been disappeared uh
and one of them was the brother of
zita caballo who lives in san francisco
and one of the members of this squad
that was on this helicopter
uh came the united states it was part of
the l'etelier mission
um
to kill orlando lately air he eventually
turned himself into u.s authorities
served i don't know something on the
order of 11 months in jail
he'd cut a plea bargain with the justice
department which seems to have included
not sending him back to chile
and they are bringing a lawsuit against
him actually in florida where he where
he lives now
to try and prosecute him so the concept
of the potential your universal
jurisdiction may it may have come to the
united states with this case we'll have
to see how it turns out but i think
there's no doubt that
that in terms of the concept of the
globalization of justice the pinochet
precedent has has certainly spurred on
other countries to to try this tactic uh
as often as they can and i think we'll
be seeing more
of those types of of prosecutions
certainly dictators former dictators
like pinochet are much more hesitant
to leave their their home bases their
sanctuaries of power
and travel abroad at this point
i thank you for your huge educational
efforts
um just a point about
there was a document released last year
about dr kissinger which covers chile
i'm not sure have you seen it
the trials of henry kissinger is that
the one you're referring to yeah it's a
documentary
have you seen that yeah i'm in that
movie and i've seen it all right
[Laughter]
second minor point is the name pinochet
sounds french is is that right is that
what is that his background is it french
and what is the what is the background
of does anybody know
he has a grandmother
[Music]
he has his grandmother is from brittany
is that uh-huh
i see
well that's the answer to that question
his grandmother's from brittany
hi
in last friday's
wall street journal
a writer argued that
pinochet really saved chile from
becoming a totalitarian state and that
um
french secret service we're training
thousands of people from around the
world revolutionaries to presumably to
help but make to help it become a
totalitarian state apart from the fact
that the wall street journal is a high
ultra-conservative newspaper and
that the writer doesn't express any
concern for the thousands that were
killed under pinochet is there any um
validity to the claim that um you know
this was going to turn into another
i don't know china i guess or
that's this point
u.s policymakers and and and
conservative uh observers of politics
such as the person who wrote that that
that article
always made assumptions about
uh about socialists
marxists
etc ain't he was a marxist but he he was
never a marxist leninist he was never a
stalinist
he had a long
very venerable and prestigious history
in chilean politics he'd run for
president three times before he actually
won
in 1970 he came very close to winning in
1958 uh which would have totally changed
the history of latin america if he had
been elected at that point and become
the first
freely elected marxist leader then uh
rather than fidel castro becoming the
model of of revolution in latin america
a year a year later
and and that was something that astute
um
ci analysts also understood that chile
represented a very different model from
from from fidel castro uh almost the
antithesis
of castro's
model
kissinger himself laid it out how
allende was going to behave he
considered it a ruse
but
it wasn't diande who
closed down the free press it wasn't
allende who invaded the universities it
wasn't allende who closed down congress
and
banned political parties and it wasn't
allende who created a secret police
force uh and
uh to to to wield repression uh to
implement a vast oppressive policy it
was it was pinochet
and all the people that argued as the
writer in the wall street journal did
never said absolutely anything about
that
there was nothing that i think
certainly allende was pressing for
substantive change in chile
more than
he had the popular support to
to implement um
he also had on his left outside of his
coalition
leftist forces
who were pro-cuba
some of them had been to cuba some of
them were working with cubans
who wanted to press along
uh his
acceleration his the momentum of of
change in chile and those forces were
just as problematic for allende as any
of his aides will will tell you as
as the right-wing forces
he didn't control them he
it was very difficult to to suppress
them although anybody was in chile at
the time knows that that many of their
protests and land seizures were were
suppressed were reversed
etc um but they created extreme problems
for him as well
was there any possibility that hindi
would have created a totalitarian system
i don't think the chilean system from
what i know of it
would have actually permitted that at no
point would he ever have been able to
take over
the military which at all points if he
had remained constitutional could have
assured the constitutional transactions
of of the future of chile
there wasn't any force
that would
juxtapose or
you know counter the force of the of the
military so when you look at the
calculations that kissinger and nixon
made i don't think any of them were uh
based in in the actual facts of the
chilean past or or or the chilean future
the argument and i'll just return to it
that kissinger nixon made was that their
efforts in chile were to preserve
democracy
there
but the extraordinary fact is that once
all of those bastions of democracy that
they uh had said they were supporting
were essentially repressed by pinochet
there was not a single effort to support
them i have in my um
i have in the book
a very interesting
story
of the debate inside the us government
of continuing to covertly support the
christian democratic party in the year
following the coup and there was a
series of arguments that were made
the ambassador davis
and then his successor ambassador popper
wanted to support the christian
democrats because they hoped that
support for them would lead them to
support the junta
the cia ironically this was the most
extraordinary the cia wanted
uh that chris to support the christian
democrats in the aftermath of the coup
because
they felt that there would eventually be
a return to the democratic process in
chile and they wanted the christian
democrats to be the strongest to be
stronger than the leftist parties which
were being repressed at that point but
might re-emerge
and
u.s officials around kissinger a few of
them wanted to support the christian
democrats because they realized how
hypocritical it would be
if they suddenly cut off aid to the one
main symbol of democracy
in chile
but kissinger and his aides decided that
they did not want to offend
pinochet
by continuing to support a political
party that he had banned
and so they authorized one minuscule
final payment of fifty thousand dollars
uh to uh the christian democratic party
and aide was
cut off i have one of the descent memos
reprinted in the book
which is well worth reading
where a mid-level state department
official says
you know
i would like to see a time when the
united states was on the right side of
history in latin america and supporting
a symbol of democracy in chile
against a government
as he wrote that can be documented to be
fascistic tyrannical militaristic and
murderous is something we should do
this is not peter cormler speaking this
is one of kissinger's aides in the state
department writing to oppose the
decision to cut off covert support
for the christian democratic party
sir thank you for what you wrote and
what you said tonight
let me say briefly that
if anything american foreign policy in
latin america has not only been right
has been extremely right dangerously
right
in fact just as vice president ford when
he became president had the great
courage to pardon richard nixon i think
he um
sinned for a serious omission of not
awarding richard up
not awarding kissinger the john foster
dallas medal for patriotism and
patriotic anti-communism
now leaving black humor aside
about 20 years ago there was a very
touching movie that was made i believe
in hollywood called missing
about that american person journalist i
believe that was caught and executed and
the efforts of his widow to find out the
action uh that movie uh without perhaps
the
all the um
you know backing of all these
declassified documents i think already
laid out very clearly what was the uh
the nature of the pinochet government
and sort of uh
served as a serious indictment against
the u.s foreign policy did you think
that he played such a role
the movie missing um was a pivotal event
uh as a hollywood product um
and as a movie that really i think
brought chile and and
uh the whole issue of u.s foreign policy
in chile to to to public attention in a
huge way
um
we a year ago my son and i went to a
major event celebrating the 20th
anniversary of of the movie in in new
york city the director constantine costa
gavras was there
joyce horman was there the real widow of
charles horman and [ __ ] spacek
who played her in the movie
was also there
and it was a movie that i suggest
everybody see anybody who i'm sure most
everybody see how many people have seen
missing
how many people haven't seen missing
very few of you haven't seen the movie
but um it's a it certainly is a movie
uh uh we're worth seeing um and i think
it had it had a huge a a huge impact on
us as as showing that the power of a of
a forceful uh hollywood movie with with
with great reach
peter as you're well aware soon after
the
coup
congressman don fraser
chair of the subcommittee house
international relations committee had a
series of hearings on chile co-chaired
with danny facell
senator kennedy
was active on the senate side
of course tom harkin is a
junior house member made a trip to chile
to what extent did these
things make any difference or were they
simply a nuisance to the kissinger or
were they or were they helpful to the
such as the lower level mid-level
official you mentioned earlier
did they have some impact on
on
working
what do you think was the difference or
impact
one anybody interested in human rights
needs to to study the case of chile the
human rights movement as we know it
today grew up
around
the chilean issue the laws that were
passed
in the offices that were just mentioned
also with senator kennedy in the senate
and
in the house
uh bonkers and vasel and and
harkin and george miller and toby
moffitt
um
really were you can call them the
pinochet kissinger laws because um they
were a response from congress to to to
kissinger's uh desire to aid pinochet
despite his despite his egregious human
rights violations
and what you can see in the documents is
how this debate and how growing
congressional pressure
infiltrated the state department and
caused henry kissinger a great upset we
had the declassified transcripts of many
of his meetings which were dominated by
him yelling
at his aides not to let ted kennedy
and
congressman bonkers get away with
be passing legislation that would
restrict kissinger's ability to give
military support and economic support to
pinochet and to other
military dictators and this comes to a
head in in meetings in in late 1974 and
mid 1975 and kissinger basically
advances three arguments that are very
important with his aides
we shouldn't let this happen because
pinochet is no worse than allende was no
worse than any other government down
there
he kind of peppers his age with this
question you know is it worse than any
other latin american countries and his
deputy has to tell him yes
and then his second argument is
basically that if we don't give this aid
to pinochet he's going to fall he's
going to collapse and this is i think
for me the most extraordinary
argument um you know
kissinger really stepped up and said i
don't want this this government
to collapse and i don't want to cut off
aid to it and i don't want there to be a
resurgence of the political forces
that it overthrew and he and he makes
this argument again and again and again
and finally his final argument was that
of course if the congress got away with
restricting aid to pinochet it would get
away with restricting aid to all all
sorts of other countries what's next he
said to his aides taiwan south korea you
know if we give them an inch they'll
take a mile that kind of that kind of
argument and finally and i just i just
have to share this with you i just have
to share this with you
he says he says this is insane he says
to you know this this congressional
efforts to restrict my ability to to to
give aid to pinochet is insane and his
deputy his assistant secretary for latin
america says it is insane
but mr secretary it does reflect an
extraordinarily strong feeling amongst
the congress as you well know
you can go to the mat on it now if you
want to and i protect predict you will
have a hell of a fight on your hands
there are a lot of democrats on the hill
this coming session who want to go to
the mat on the issue of human rights and
want to make a fight about it it is very
hard to make a national interest
argument on chile the human rights issue
has caught the imagination up on the
hill as you well know mr secretary and
amongst the american people
my diagnosis is the reason they've stuck
to it they've stuck it to the department
in this case is that they don't think we
are sincere on human rights
and
that was
uh william rogers assistant secretary
for latin america speaking to to
kissinger in the in a meeting
um in
late 1974
i think it gives you a sense from the
inside of the impact that the work that
a number of people even in this room
including yourself were doing at the
time
and how it was uh and how it was
bringing pressure um on
on henry kissinger's policies towards
chile
yes my dear
i want to say as a chilean
looking back you know the chilean
government of allende was always caught
in the struggle in the internal struggle
and beside that with the foreign policy
of the united states
again the first thing that he did in his
government was to nationalize the copper
mine
our raw material our sport as he used to
say the budget of the chilean people the
salary of our workers
then he touched a very sensitive point
you know for the american interests
beside that the internal problem you
know was within the parties
always the christian democracy
was trying to make
a parallel between the leftist coalition
with the cuban revolution
and as an agenda used to say always this
is a revolution meaning that is going to
be a big change
but in liberty
and he really committed himself
when was demanded by our congress that
never would be you know
violated our constitution
the result of all this sad you know
situation the involvement of the cia
the foreign american foreign policy and
so you know is that up to now
we have not recovered our democracy
we don't have a full democracy in chile
because still we are ruled by the
constitution of pinochet
that he designated some senators
and we
we are we are struggling for that
we don't have majority when i say we
don't have you know the elected it
doesn't matter
right or left but pinochet constitution
is the one that is ruling chile up to
now
and that is the reason that mr pinochet
that was declared insane
you know he socialized i met him in a
cafe in santiago chile one month ago
very happy the insane just see
but i want to say only that
i become emotional
well it wasn't it wasn't a question
it wasn't a question but it was a
very important comment go ahead
i'm really humbled to follow such
eloquence with two fairly mundane
questions but the first one the in the
trials of henry kissinger um he speaks
the the documentarian speaks about the
case of renee schneider's family um
against kissinger on the morning of
september 11 2001 getting completely you
know obviously uh over overturned by all
that else went on that day
what is the current status of that case
and then my second question is just you
know listening to you tonight and these
documents
i i i walk away here feeling such um
such pessimism such sadness about how
little we've learned um from this
particularly in the current
circumstances that we face with our our
senior officials do you have any more
optimism and hope about this than i am
left with tonight
not really
darn
the case of renee schneider is one that
was investigated by the senate committee
in 1975
there were a number of documents it
turns out that was were not shown to
that committee and and i've been able to
to read them and use them in in
revisiting that case again
i actually gave the first chapter of the
book
several years ago to 60 minutes and they
said they found out that the family of
renee schneider was going to sue henry
kissinger and richard helms the cia
director um
for wrongful death uh in a u.s court
this was as again in the aftermath of
the impact of of pinochet's arrest and
the possibility that that a crime
committed there and chile could perhaps
be prosecuted here at least in uh
in a as under
not a not a criminal
case but as a civil case
and um 60 minutes did air on on sunday
night september 9
2001
a piece that all about the schneider
case with the new documents and um and
the whole issue of kissinger's uh
potential or alleged responsibility uh
in in this episode um the case was then
filed in u.s court the next day on
september 10th and on the morning of
september 11th the washington post ran a
very long story
but of course by the afternoon of
september 11th dr kissinger was
on television and actually talking about
how the senate investigation
into alleged assassinations of foreign
leaders in the mid 1970s had restricted
the cia from being able to assassinate
people like osama bin laden
and that that really was the villain
here that congress had somehow undermine
our ability to to to carry out executive
action against osama bin laden um so
he'd become you know an advocate of of
uh assassination of course he was
mistaken the clinton administration had
been trying for three years to
assassinate osama bin laden the cia had
carte blanche to to get him whenever it
could and it just hadn't been able to
that the the opportunities he had that
that the agency had had
were too narrow too small involved too
many civilian casualties
and they had not been able to to carry
out uh this this
mission
certainly i think chile does resonate
today and um
i haven't dwelled as much as i could
have on
on the misrepresentation of this policy
um
but honesty in government became a big
issue in the aftermath of the chilean
case u.s officials had repeatedly
testified to congress that our policy in
chile
was to have the type of relations with
allende that he wanted to have with us
and we have the declassified documents
which shows that that is absolutely
false dr kissinger testified before the
senate
on in september of 1974 he was asked
about chile about the u.s role in the
coup and he said it was not our policy
to subvert or destabilize
the allende government and we have the
declassified documents now where
meeting after meeting after meeting he
pushes
and authorizes and directs exactly that
that policy and those documents are are
in the book for
for anybody to see
and so i think that is that is an issue
again chile was a very different case
than the types of cases we're
confronting today it was a
democratically elected government that
had never repressed anybody that had
never threatened the united states with
violence did not have weapons of mass
destruction
was not a terrorist regime etc this was
about covert
intervention
not about overt
intervention but some of the same issues
that have been debated over the last
year were internally at least debated
as this policy unfolded
in in chile and then certainly in the
aftermath of the coup
chile became the catalyst for the first
national debate over the propriety of
covert operations
and the first national debate
over institutionalizing human rights as
a criteria
of our
foreign
policy we are now into a debate over
humanitarian intervention there was
obviously a major issue
uh about a major difference uh clearly
there is a major difference between um
between uh overthrowing a tyrant and
installing one and so there's there are
grave differences but but in the broad
themes chile does offer a lot of lessons
and most of them don't seem to be
to be being learned right at this moment
hi peter
my question follows on from that
question in your comments
somebody once said i think that what we
learned from the close study of history
is that we don't learn from history
and in fact so much of what went wrong
in a fundamental sense with the u.s
policy and manipulation in chile
has been hidden except over time with
you and others so courageously and
skillfully drawing it forth
painfully drawing it forth and a lot of
it's still in the shadows and now we
have a government that's behaving in
that fashion
at least as uh
with at least as much effect and malign
intent as nixon and kissinger ever did i
mean i was going to ask what your sense
of hopefulness about that was but you
should have answered that maybe the
thing to ask is
the slender
kind of avenue toward a truthful
understanding that's the only platform
on which better and more honest policies
can be fought for
is to know as much of what went on as
possible
and therefore national security archives
and the case study of the chilean papers
gives us one example of that
how are you and the endeavor to have
that kind of access that kind of release
of public documents and therefore
some glimmer of the truth how is that
fairing under george w bush
currently
an administration that is so steeped in
secrecy and doing it behind closed doors
i mean how do you see the future of the
generic effort to get public revelation
of the public's business
a difficult and hard road
uh
uh
under the the justification of fighting
terrorism
secrecy has been
significantly expanded in our government
circles and in almost every realm
you'd be interested to know that there
are documents that have been
declassified on the shelves of the
national archives for years
that have now been
reclassified
are under review
and are being censored even though
they've been sitting on the shelves for
for many years because of a changing
criteria over what should be open to the
public and what shouldn't be open to the
public
um
and
obviously in the difficult situation
that we're in uh
the arguments for further secrecy
are being made
being institutionalized and being
implemented
it's going to be harder to get
presidential papers in the future it's
going to be harder to use the freedom of
information act
i think that you'll still be able to get
documents on foreign policy episodes
going back to the 70s
but more recent issues are going to be
very difficult
we will re-meet here in 30 years
on the anniversary of the war of iraq to
study whatever declassified documents we
are possibly able to get by that time
and i can guarantee you even if we do
that
um we won't have all the documents 30
years from now because many of them will
still be secret 30 years from now i i
believe
it was the famous philosopher that once
said you know sunlight is the best
disinfectant
and
that is particularly true when it comes
to transparency in government
there's no doubt that the world has
changed there's no doubt that u.s
policies have to be different
given what happened to us
two years ago
but to use secrecy
and expand secrecy under the guise of
fighting terrorism is in the end going
to be a formula for the types of
activities that we've seen in the past
that as colin powell put it
weren't proud moments for our country
i'm going to stop you've been so
wonderful to sit here i appreciate it
i'm going to sit here and sign a few
books if anybody wants their book signed
but thank you so very much for coming
the pinochet file a declassified dossier
on atrocity and accountability is
published by the new press on the web at
newpress.com
[Music]
it's book tv's fifth anniversary this
fall on c-span 2